in this video I want to talk about the
similarities and differences between the
electron transport chain and the
photosynthetic light reaction
specifically so they have some
similarity some things in common both of
them have electron flow and this
electron flow is through a chain of
membrane bound carriers that includes
the quinone cytochromes iron sulfur
clusters etc so the fact there's
electron flow means both of these
processes have redox reactions now these
redox reactions many of them typically
are spontaneous and exergonic right and
photosynthesis and electron invent the
electron transport chain differs
slightly in this regard but that's
something I'll get to when I talk about
the differences but both of them have
electron flow through change of membrane
bound carriers and they both have redox
reactions in addition both of them use
these redox reactions to establish
proton gradients which are also pH
gradients these gradients are across a
membrane so what happens here is the
downhill flow of electrons right the
spontaneous flow of electrons so the
redox reactions drives the uphill flow
of protons right the protons are being
pumped into an a region that has a high
concentration of protons so that these
protons are moving against their
gradient and these electrons moving down
down there
downhill in that they're moving to
higher reduction potentials so both
established proton gradients across a
membrane through the spontaneous flow of
electrons and once both of them have
these established proton gradients
they both couple the downhill
flow of protons back across the membrane
through specific protein channels in the
mitochondria that protein channel is the
f0 subunit and in chloroplasts it's the
cf0 subunit and then with
phosphorylation of ADP to make ATP which
is done by the f1 subunit in
mitochondria and the CF one subunit in
chloroplast and either in both cases
we're talking about ATP synthase right
those subunits are part of the ATP
synthase enzyme which actually makes the
ATP s so they both have this
chemiosmotic coupling they both use the
spontaneous flow of protons back down
their gradients to power the production
of ATP some differences about them
though so what is or what are the
initial and terminal electron donors and
carriers respectively in both cases in
mitochondria we have initial donors the
initial electron donors are reduced
coenzymes and if you recall those are
nadh and fadh2 now these two are willing
to give up their electrons so they won't
they are good reducing agents okay and
the terminal electron acceptor is of
course oxygen oxygen oxidizes things so
it's actually a pretty great oxidizing
agent the chloroplasts try again I just
want to reiterate here that we're
talking about the light reactions
photosynthesis the chloroplasts the
initial electron donor is water right
and water does not want to be oxidized
so it's a poor reducing agent and
because it doesn't want to be reduced
excuse me it doesn't want to be oxidized
since it doesn't want to be oxidized it
doesn't want to reduce anything it
doesn't want to be oxidized to oxygen it
requires energy and that energy comes
from light the terminal electron
acceptor is in a TP Plus which of course
turns into NADPH now we mentioned
earlier that both of them establish
proton gradients but how is the proton
gradient established in each one well in
the mitochondria there are two things
that contribute to establishing the
proton gradient whereas in the
chloroplast there are three different
things so only in the electron transport
chain of the mitochondria the one thing
that contributes to the proton gradient
is the pumping of protons from the
matrix to the intermembrane space and
this is done by complexes 1 3 & 4 so if
they're taking protons from the matrix
to the intermembrane space what's
happening well we're taking protons out
of the matrix so we're lowering the
proton concentration in the matrix and
we're taking them to the intermembrane
space so we're increasing the H+
concentration in the intermembrane space
in addition the other thing that makes
that is that establishes the proton
gradient and the mitochondria is making
water and that occurs in the matrix so
if we're forming water by reducing
oxygen then oxygen needs to pick up
protons that's happening in the matrix
so what this does is this lowers the
proton concentration of the matrix
because the oxygen picks up these
protons and then form as water so those
protons no longer free-floating in the
matrix so what's the net result here we
have a low concentration of H pluses in
the mitochondrial matrix which would be
a high pH and then we have a high H+
concentration to build the protons in
the intermembrane space which would mean
a low pH okay so that's the net result
overall
from these two processes now in the
chloroplast we also have a proton
gradient established but it's
established in a different way the first
thing that happens is the splitting of
water in the thylakoid lumen so if we
take water and we oxidize it right we
break it up into oxygen and protons
those protons perfectly floating and
that this is happening in the thylakoid
lumen then these protons would be is a
proton concentration in the lumen would
increase so we'd have a higher
concentration of protons in the lumen
the second thing that contributes to the
gradient is the electron flow from
photosystem ii to photosystem 1 so this
is when plasto quinone pumps protons
from the stroma into the thylakoid lumen
so this they're taking it out of the
stroma
so that's lowering the concentration of
protons in the stroma I'm taking them to
the thylakoid lumen which would increase
the proton concentration in the lumen
the last thing is that nadp+
right is reduced to NADPH right and this
happens in the stroma so if these
protons are in the stroma they get
tacked on nadp+ that means we're taking
protons out of the stroma essentially so
we're lowering the H+ concentration in
this drama so what's the net result is
that we have a low concentration of H+
is in the stroma which is of course as a
high pH and then we have a high proton
concentration or a low pH and the
thylakoid lumen last thing I want to
mention is what are the differences in
the end energetics of each process so in
the electron transport chain every
single step of that transport chain is
exergonic so since every step is
exergonic then the overall process
itself oops I was going to write overall
the overall process itself is exergonic
or spontaneous and the phosphorylation
of ad of ADP to make ATP is
basically just it's powered by the
establishing the proton gradient which
is for me it's powered by the proton
gradient or the protons flowing back
down the gradient but how was the
gradient established through these redox
reactions these exergonic redox
reactions so this is called oxidative
phosphorylation right because these
redox reactions powered the establishing
of the gradient and all of them were
exergonic steps in the chloroplasts
however in the light reaction there are
two steps of the light reactor light
reaction themselves that are exergonic
which is me endergonic sorry two steps
of the light reaction are endergonic
there are two steps right when we shine
the light on the reaction centers that
in order to oxidize the reaction centers
at the chlorophylls
those require light energy and there are
therefore endergonic the rest of the
reactions however are exergonic because
they all have electron flow based on
reduction potentials no energy is is
invested so now in in chloroplasts we
have some reactions that are endergonic
two of them to be specific whereas the
recs are at rest are exergonic now but
what is the overall process well if you
sum up the Delta G's from all these
reactions and all these reactions what
you end up getting is an overall
endergonic process the entire process
itself requires light and so because of
that essentially what they call it here
is the phosphorylation is driven by the
energy of light and is therefore called
photophosphorylation so I hope that
video kind of sums up the sort of
general idea as far as these
similarities and differences go thanks
for watching